Jenin your career as a consultant I
understand you've worked with hundreds
of writers many of whom have gone on to
be staffed as writers on shows they've
sold pilots what are you doing that you
feel has made the difference to those
who's crossed over versus those who
haven't or maybe there's not one thing
it's sort of based on a full package I
think it's based on many things I would
say part of what I do with writers is
emotionally I help them to work on what
is holding them back so just as in story
we understand there is a weakness or a
flaw that is stopping the hero from
achieving the goal with the writers that
I work with I help them to work on what
do they feel internally is holding them
back and very often I think I can say
writers who grasp my story system on
structure mixed with they believe that
they're going to be a working writer is
what leads them to the outcome so I
would say it's you know that's the ideal
situation it could be one or the other
as well like I I think story just like
in life like when I think about
everything that I learned through my 17
years of working in the business before
I started my own business and the knocks
that I went through during that time and
the ego that was involved in a lot of
that and how through moving through the
obstacles and then hitting in all of
last moment really led me to a deeper
part of the life process I think it's
the same for writers and as you
mentioned earlier I also think that
writers can be an old soul at an
due to what happens in their life
process and writers could come into
writing at 50 plus and really have
something to say and have it really
thought out incredibly well and I think
it's through I'm a definite believer
that through the story structure process
mixed with the emotional work and the
belief in the writing is what leads to
the outcome and part of the work that I
do is because I mean I've been working
in the business 24 or 25 years now so I
can tell them where they're at
I can instill belief which I have to say
it's probably one of the greatest
there's nothing I love more than reading
a script and being able to say to the
writer you are tremendously talented you
have a gift and this is your calling and
helping them to believe that do you have
them do a personal inventory of what
they thinks holding them back and if you
do how much of that really matches up
for what you see I would say our
negative narratives are so internally
ingrained that I would say it's rare
that we can pinpoint it like certainly
in my process now I mean the great thing
is now many writers are doing five
coaching sessom sessions with me and
through the five coaching sessions the
great thing for me is I can see things
like that I can see what is holding them
back and what they need to work on like
there are a lot of times where you can
have incredibly talented people who
don't believe it or don't see it and so
they get in their own way
of the outcome happening so through the
coaching process you are able to help
them see you know what is working like
Aaron Spelling taught me always always
always start your notes with what works
about the story before you dive into
what could be better
and I think through through doing that
with writers I have come to recognize a
lot of my meetings I will do in the way
of the first 20 minutes we'll talk about
what's going on in your life right now
how was writing these this last week or
last couple weeks how did you feel about
what you wrote
our rewrote in your script this week
were there any hurdles that held you
back and why do you think they held you
back held you back and I think through
going through the process of what is
moving them forward versus what is
holding them back it does help shed
light on where they need to focus on I
know you someone mentioned in another
interview with you that you have an
ability to make people feel safe and I
definitely feel that right now when you
meet with someone who you feel these
walls up and it's a lot of ego and
hubris and maybe they're not sharing
weaknesses is there a way to kind of get
them comfortable because some people
don't feel okay with weakness some
people on the flip side and that's all
they know and they get all their
narrative is yeah and then there's
others that anything they say they're
always on top and I've seen that a lot
yes in LA so how do you sometimes make
that person more human I think that is a
great question I would say the biggest
way I go into that as I give an example
I'll say when I staffed 15 shows and I
would meet with writers up to an hour at
a time
what I was looking for in that hour is
are they accessible to their own story
they could they might be able to say
this happened to me this happened to me
this happened to me but not be
vulnerable in the revelation of that
process and a large part of what I was
looking for staffing wise was is that a
well that can be accessed or is the ego
or is the wall too big to where it isn't
something that is penetrable so I think
in and I will talk with writers about
this directly I'll say things like you
need to recognize that your gold as a
writer is being able to communicate what
you've gone through and recognize that
it's almost like you need to detach from
your story and not connect shame with it
it's your story it's what you're drawing
from and I'm going to tell you
executives the greatest thing they want
to know is how big is your well and and
the the more vulnerability that you show
in a meaning with regards to why you'd
be the perfect writer to write on this
show and have a backup of personal
stories that exemplify why you'd be the
best writer that's what will land you a
job
so being vulnerable is key in that
process and the flipside the one that's
just the open wound and it's all gold
but you know at some point you got to
pull it together dad I get some stuff
going what do you tell that person well
that's the healing process too like I
can tell you I've had 10 friends with
cancer since my own divorce
I've probably helped 25 people through
divorce and there is like when you first
go through
the divorce are the diagnosis there is a
crazy time that's happening
psychologically an absolute shift has
happened in your world and and that
shift can cause you to be overly
emotional overly emotional and yet the
gift is being that be in the over
emotion and know that it is going to
scale back in time so I think if I have
a writer who's too raw and too in it
I'll say to them like maybe now isn't
the right time for you to explore this
specific thing maybe you should take a
break from this and write something that
is a little removed from the pain that
is involved with this story and I have
found that works a lot and then when
they come back to it they're ready to
move through it like say for example
when I wrote change or story change your
life it was enough time had passed since
I had gone through that loss that I was
ready to explore it and I was ready to
be responsible for my own part in the
outcome and I I think when you're going
through healing and when you're going
through trauma that it's just part of
the life process so I think there's in
my opinion and advantage to being over
emotional but knowing when you have to
scale back and when you have to take a
break and then rheic Splore so that you
can utilize that emotion but come from a
stronger place because you have more
time to process it
you